Oh ouais
n 4 jours
vaudou moi
Ouais
4 jours
[applaudissements]
Je ne sais pas si je ferai quelque chose si je le ramène à la maison.
Mais quand je le regarde, j'en deviens reconnaissant
Si cela signifie que je peux vivre ici, je le veux vraiment
Il se sent bien
Bon, c'est un pseudo, mais c'est un peu un jeu d'écureuil, mais ce que je veux
La relation y est incroyable avec Omine
[musique]
avoir 50 ans et dire
aucun
action
Ouais
tu es le premier
[musique]
grognement
vaudou
Celle du haut était déjà prise par la maison précédente.
En dessous se trouve le beau billet de 10 000 yens
Hivernage
J'étais ici parce que j'avais quelque chose, mais ça
ici
4 Je ne peux pas le supporter Je veux être quelque part sur mon ordinateur
augmenter
[musique]
Waouh
Ahhh
le son est entré
pon pon
aller
mal
tee
Wow Wow